simplifica la siguiente expresión 4x
cuadrada
3x y 25 y a todo eso le vamos a restar 9
cuadrada x + 7 x menos 20 muy bien esto
es exactamente lo mismo que restar
individualmente cada uno de estos
términos o bien que distribuir el signo
menos o bien que pensarlo como un -1 y
multiplicar cada uno de los términos
todo eso es exactamente lo mismo
entonces vamos a hacer eso primero vamos
a reescribir el lado izquierdo así
igualito porque ahí no hay ningún signo
menos que nos esté dando lata 4x
cuadrada menos 3 x 725 más 25 y ahora sí
vamos a distribuir este signo menos en
color naranja y a ver - por 9 cuadrada x
este con éste nos quedaría menos 9
cuadrada x ahora este menos con este 7x
pues simplemente hace que el 7x ya tenga
signo menos menos 7 x y finalmente este
menos con este menos 20 pues pensando
esto como un menos uno menos uno por
menos 20 nos da
20 porque menos por menos es más este
término de acá ok entonces ya no tenemos
paréntesis ya únicamente tenemos que
sumar o restar los términos similares
vamos a hacerlo déjame empezar con este
término de acá lo voy a poner de color
rojo entonces 4 x cuadrada y tenemos
otra cosa de la forma x cuadrada y en
nuestra expresión pues éste no este no
este no es nuestro no únicamente tenemos
este 4x cuadrada y entonces lo voy a
copiar así 4 x cuadrada y igualito va
ahora vamos con términos de la forma x
como este de aquí lo voy a poner en
color rosa
tenemos un menos 3 x y hay otro si aquí
hay otro este es menos 7 x si a menos 3
x le restamos 7 x y xi tenemos menos
tres cosas y nos quitan otras 7 entonces
nos quedan menos 10 x 10 menos 37 es
menos 10 ahora vamos con este 25 este 25
es un término constante
este término constante pues acá tiene
otro compañero verdad este 20 también es
constante entonces tendríamos que hacer
la suma 25 con 20 que es 45 más 45 y
finalmente nos queda este término de
aquí que voy a poner en color azul en
color azul y este claramente ya no se
puede juntar con nadie más porque ya
contamos a todos con todos y entonces
nos queda menos 9 cuadrada x
listo ya realizamos la resta y nos quedó
4x cuadrada y menos 10 x 45 menos nueve
cuadrada x